ومن الكويت ينضم الينا الدكتور سعد بن
طفله وزير الاعلام السابق دكتور سعد مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في النشره الرابعه من
الرياض الدكتور بدايه كيف تقرا حصاد سنه
2022 من السياسي في الكويت
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه عام 22 اعتقل بان عام مفصلي في
عده مفاصل حدثت في طبعا تعهد السلطه لاول
مره
واعترافها ضمني بانها كانت تتدخل
بالانتخابات السابقه وتعهدها هذه المره
بعدم التدخل وهو ما شهد له الجميع ويسجل
لها الحقيقه همم ولذلك جاءت انتخابات الى
درجه عاليه من النزاهه رغم انني مثلا
متحفظ على بقاء يعني الدوائر على ما هي
عليه صوت واحد ومعي الكثيرين من المتحفظين
الحقيقه همم لكن هذه الانتخابات نتج عنها
ازاحه خلنا نقول الحكومه السابقه برئيسها
وازاحه البرلمان السابق او معظم اعضاء
البرلمان السابق
وفي خطاب اسمه ولي العهد خطاب
ولي العهد في 22 يونيو قال او القى باللوم
على تلك العلاقه المتوتره بين السلطتين
على الرئاستين رئاسه البرلمان ورئاسه
الحكم
السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعه مع
التشريعيه طبعا مع بعضهما البعض بعد حل
البرلمان بعد تغيير الحكومه ايضا لمرتين
قدوم رئيس حكومه جديده
صحيح ولذلك انا اعتقد ان لا زالت هذه
الحكومه حتى بعد تغير رئيسها وتشكيلها
جديد وتشكيلها الاخير يعني تعاني من مطبات
كثيره ليس سرا بانه وزير الدفاع قد قدم
استقالته وبانه اجازه مفتوحه لكن الان
يعني لم يعلن قبولها رسميا ولكن هذا مؤشر
الى مدى الازمه التي تعيش الحكومه ومؤشر
الى المطبات القادمه التي سوف تقع بها
الحكومه في مواجهه البرلمان ممتاز همم
تحدثت عن نقطه مهمه قبل قليل همم يعني في
ثنايا حديثه تتحدثون عن غياب شخصيه الرئيس
السابق للبرلمان همم مجلس الامه الكويتيه
مرزوق الغانم عن المشهد اللي برلماني هل
لك من اي تعليق على غياب هذه الشخصيه كيف
انعكس غيابها ايضا حتى على المشهد
البرلماني والسياسي في الكويت
الاجابه على هذا السؤال في العام 23
بصراحه في العام القادم بمعنى اذا استطاع
هذا البرلمان ان يحرك الملفات الاساسيه
التي تمس حياه الانسان من رفع مستوى
المعيشه ووقف ارتفاع الاسعار والتضخم
ومحاربه الفساد وحل اشكاليه الجنسيه
والبدون والدوائر الانتخابيه والصوت
الواحد وحق الانسان في اللجوء الى المحكمه
في حاله نزع الجنسيه منه اعتقد بان اذا
استطاعوا ان يحققه ذلك في هذا البرلمان
سيقول الناس اي شفت شلون هذا من بسبب
مرزوق الغانم ومجلسهم لكن اذا لم يتحقق
هذا الشيء ايضا سيكون الناس هذا معناه ان
انتم خصومتكم مع مرزوق الغانم كان شخصيا
والدليل ان انت ما سويتوا شيء مثل المجلس
مرزوق الغانم وبالتالي انا اقول ان
الاجابه تكون في الايام القادمه وان كنت
غير متفائل همم
في الفترات الاخيره غير متفائله يا دكتور
سعد بالوضع القادم في الكويت ده ينسحب على
2013 كمان افهم الان حتى
ان
ني صحيح ان يعني في همم يعني تغيرات خلينا
نقول جذريه في مح
اسبيه للفساد لكنها لا نرى يعني
استراتيجيه شامله نحن نرى مثلا على سبيل
المثال تغيير في القيادات واستقالات في
القيادات طيب هل هذا يعني القيادات هذه مو
بالضروره كلها تحتهم حولها شبهات يعني همم
كثير منهم الحقيقه وبعضهم يعني يشهد لها
بالنزاهه وبالعمل الجاد واعطي همم قراءات
من اجل التقاعد المبكر وذهب وقدموا
استقالاتهم طيب ما هو البديل هل انت يعني
السؤال الذي يطرح لنا الناس يعني هل نحن
فعلا ندخل بعهد جديد اتمنى ان انا لا تقول
لفرقه جديده بدلا من الفرق القديمه هذا هو
السؤال الذي يطرحه الناس ويتردد على سنتين
الان هل يمكن ان تستمر هذه العلاقه بين
المجلس والحكم انا ما اعتقد بان هذا الشيء
سيتم لان الاليات التي كان يتم بها وادوات
الصدام التي كانت تحدث في الماضي لا زالت
قائمه وعليه فاننا لا نستطيع ان نجرب
المجرب ونعتقد باننا يمكن ان نخرج بنتيجه
دكتور اسلام السياسي لازال نشيطا في
الكويت وثيقه القيم مثلا اخذت حيزا كبيرا
من الجده بين الشدو في المجتمع الكويتي
وانا عكس ذلك ربما ايضا على الاراء في
موقع التواصل الاجتماعي كذلك ايضا حتى
لجنه الظواهر
السلبيه كيف تقيم هذا الوضع كيف تقيم نشاط
الاسلام السياسي في الكويت في هذا العام
شوف يعني خلنا نتكلم بعموميه وبعدين ادخل
لك في الشان الكويتيه اريني في هذا العالم
اييي يعني ديمقراطيه يساهم فيها الاسلام
السياسي بعمليه سلسه
متوائمه ومتوافقه لا يوجد
لا في العراق ولا في ايران ولا في لبنان
ولا في غزه ولا في تونس ولا في اي مكان
وبالتالي انت لازم تكون واقعي مع نفسك
يعني الاسلام السياسي هو يحمل فكر مناقب
تماما له شيء دستور وتعايش وحريه وتبادل
سلطه لانه يريد ان يقيم دوله دينيه
بمفهومه هو طبعا الاجسام السياسي بفرعيه
الاسلام السياسي استني يريد اقامه الخلافه
والاسلام السياسي الشيعي يريد اقامه دوله
الولايه او التبعيه لدوله الولايه هذا
واحد اثنين في
موضوع واهل السلبيه
هي انتخابات ليش
متحمسين يقول لهم حنه ترى ما احنا مشاركين
الديمقراطيه والانتخابات علشان الكراسي لا
هو من اجل يعني لوجه الله ومن اجل ان نقيم
حدود الله ومن اجل كذا كذا سبقنا قدمه مثل
هذا الموضوع الى يعني حكم الدستوريه وقالت
المحكمه الدستوريه بانني لا نستطيع ان
نقدم احكاما ما لم تحدد لي ما هي الظواهر
السلبيه وبالتالي يسقط هذا المفهوم لكن
هذا للاستهلاك طبعا ولل يعني
البساطه والناس الطيبين اعتقادا منهم بان
ما في ديمقراطيه في العالم ولا في برلمان
العالم يحاول التضييق على حريات الناس
البرلمانات في العالم تحاول دائما ان توسع
الحريات الناس وليس حتى ما ينص عليها
الدستور الكويتي توسيع الحريات وليس تضيقه
همم دكتور سعد انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر ما
تبقى هذه الكثير من الوقت همم شكرا لك من
الكويت او من اسبانيا الينا الدكتور سعد
بن طفله وزير الاعلام الكويت السابق